Michael course writing has appeared in
Wired and he writes extensively on
science he is also a consultant for
educational computing he is here tonight
with his technological memoir rebuilt
how becoming part computer made me more
human following the reading he'll be
happy to take questions if he hasn't
answered questions already
and then afterwards we'll be signing
just to my right so please help me in
welcoming to the University Bookstore
michael chorost thank you all for coming
you know it's great to see you all out
here now before we get started why do a
sound check is the mic turned on are you
getting it okay free okay see I can
never tell how loud things are because
I'm totally deaf I only hear my own
voice when it goes into the device that
I'm wearing and into my head and I can
change my volume level so which means I
never know how inherently loud anything
actually is so I always have to do sound
checks so let me introduce my book and
talk a little bit about some of the
themes in the book is as the introduces
that it is a technological memoir it is
a story of going completely deaf and
gaining my hearing back when the
implanted computer which you can see
right on the cover of the book that is
my skull on the cover people ask me that
and if you're not convinced you can see
that you can actually see the outline of
my face on the cover because a cat scan
captures soft tissue as well as bone so
that really is my face I think I may be
the only author in publishing history
that a picture of the insiders had and
the outside of his head on the same book
cover I don't know if anyone else has
that distinction if you know if anybody
felt tell me because I'll be very
disappointed so let me just start off
forthwith with the beginning of the book
which sets up some of the ideas that
flowed through the book so I'm going to
start on page page one I'm going to read
two pages
I'm impatience it hasn't been a good
morning I'm on a business trip and have
just arrived in Reno where I'm supposed
to interview people at Tahoe for a study
but the chloromethyl at the airport
won't take my debit card I spent half an
hour canvassing the other outlets no
luck finally a man at one counter kindly
named the competitor and point me to a
courtesy phone dial 133 they usually
have cars and their rates are okay I
pick up the phone
I can hear a fine even amid the ruckus
of the baggage claim yes they have cars
available the voice directory to the
shuttle bus outside the airport at the
last telephone call I will ever make
with my natural ears people are signed I
wait for my car I pigeon I might as well
have driven here instead of flying and
then that's odd the traffic sounds fuzzy
all of a sudden instead of the usual
decisive grump the cars have started
making a whispering sound as they go by
as if plowing through shredded paper and
they sound a hundred yards away even
though I'm right by the road it sounds
like my left hearing aids battery is
going even though I'm wearing two
hearing aids only the left ear really
counts the right ear is so poor that I
can only hear vague rumbles my left ear
is my conversation ear my telephone ear
my radio ear I switch back batteries in
a practice little potty do of the hands
left battery into the right white
battery into the left that doesn't make
any difference
I guess they're both going and as a
matter of fact I have to interrupt
myself because the battery my plane just
died at this very moment so this is
actually a great opportunity for me to
introduce the implant itself now this is
what we call the processor and I'll hold
it up for a moment so the camera can get
a good look at it
it looks like a hearing aid it's not a
hearing it's actually a computer its
output is data whereas a hearing aids
out port is sound so here's how it works
sound got is in a microphone in the
headpiece a little dot right there
now have you send it to the processor
which is this device here this is the
battery which has just gone dead this
processes sound sends it back to the
headpiece the Hat cheese will stick to
my head just like that
the reason it sticks to my head is
because there's a magnet in it inside
the implant there is also a magnet and
you can see the implant itself on the
cover of the book so this device here
behind my ear is the actual body of the
implant itself the implant is embedded
in my skull and it has 16 electrodes
that govern each one half inside my
skull they trigger auditory nerve
endings in rapid sequence to stimulate
the auditory nerves my brain has learned
to interpret that as sound now normally
a wait a bit in reading to explain that
except my battery just went dead so I
took that opportunity something
extraordinary coincidence I'm just
talking about I thought my batteries are
dying
lo and behold my batteries actually died
so let's come back to the reading I
guess they're both going both batteries
I pull out a battery pack for my
suitcase do a second change and wait for
the familiar rush a clean loud sound but
it doesn't happen I can't have two
broken hearing aids at once it's as
absurd as two tires blowing out at the
same time as I get in the car and
breathing shallowly and it's not because
of the altitude I roll the car window
down fiddle with my left hearing its
volume control and wait for my ears to
miraculously clear all the way up to
Tahoe I'm monitoring on all frequencies
and
this doesn't sound right gotta be the
batteries it's just a pack of bad
batteries at the hotel I check in then
gods the longs drug store and buy three
sets of 675
it cost me 15 dollars and 37 cents right
there at the checkout counter and rip
the batteries out of the plastic case
and put them in that doesn't help either
in the car I spread both hearing aids
out on the passenger seat and
methodically try every possible
combination of terms batteries and ear
molds nothing works
the day is like a coin that always comes
up tails
it's got to be earwax I say to myself
out loud looking out the windshield at
the big red and white logo of the store
I've got to get someone to check my left
ear for ear wax leave the clerk of the
hotel she had proved to be a listen
woman with blond hair layered over black
whose pole have spouted as her hands
explored a keyboard at Clinton see maybe
she would also take me into her arms and
tell me that everything would be all
right now that would be customer service
that never had earwax trouble in my life
but I've also never had two hearing aids
failing me at once either emergency room
now so that's how the book starts and
that happened on July 7th 2001 at 10:30
in the morning so as a matter of fact I
just passed the fourth anniversary of my
death ding the day that I went
completely deaf so the book takes you
through the process of what it was like
to be completely deaf and tweaked after
the sheer shock of having the computer
take over my hearing and that's what I
was trying to convey in the book and
trying to go beyond how did the book be
a memoir of just on death and gain my
hearing back that's a remarkable story
in itself I wanted to go further to talk
about what it was like that computer
controlling my hearing
so let me talk a little bit about that
computer and by the way the way I'd like
to do readings it did some reading and
talking for a while take some questions
do some more reading so once I show you
this device I'd like to invite you to
ask some questions and we'll do some Q&A
I like that kind of backward forth
process so this is a cochlear implant it
doesn't look like much in a distance but
this is 40 years of research and
development
this device cost about eighteen thousand
dollars its actual value this device is
zero because this is the device that
failed quality testing so it was
rejected that's why I'm holding it here
instead of me implant it inside a
person's body so I'll pass it around be
careful not to yank on this because this
is the leads that go to the electrode
array at the very end now the tip of it
doesn't look like much it just looks
like a long piece of plastic but that
again is the product of decades of
research and development let's curl that
inside the inner ear inside the cochlea
and there are sixteen tiny electrodes
and you can see them if you look closely
on it those electrons are which
stimulate the auditory nerve endings now
one of the things that I'd get a big
kick out of in looking at this device is
it says Advanced Bionics Clarion
platinum series model a B zero five one
zero zero H this side end now that just
completely cracks me up because the
screen have to put it this side out
instead of this way sorry J so just keep
it this side out and by the way you can
see that's why I hit P sticks to my head
because it just sticks to the magnet
inside the implant
so I'll pass this around yeah could you
pass that along
thank you now does anybody have any
questions that they would like to ask
before I go on yes sir today is their
chance someday they'll have 32 or 64
there is research going on in developing
electrode arrays to have a larger number
of electrons
yes sir chance the big K can be if they
get one can they put one in you that is
possible it's not likely because turns
are reluctant to X plans that is remove
a device that's functioning properly
because you run the risk of doing
additional damage to the cochlea that's
the question if much of the device does
a small amount of damage they do a
tremendous amount of research to make
that insertion as non traumatic as
possible but still and it'd be moving it
runs the risk of additional damage now
that said there are number of patients
with had their devices fail and so the
surgeon does remove the device importing
a new one and if the newer ones are more
advanced devices they'll get a more
advanced device in research has shown
that those patients tend to do as well
more better with their it with the new
implant as they date with the old one so
it is proving to be feasible in practice
but still I don't know if any surgeon
that would remove a properly functioning
device for the purpose of upgrading you
that's why the device upgradable through
software and that's the primary way of
operating the device or loading new
software into the processor the
processor uploads a subset of that
software each of the device itself so
the device itself is very much
controlled by the software that's
written important that is one of the
major themes of the book talk about
different kinds of software profoundly
changed my perception of reality and in
a moment I'll read one of those sections
any any other question is yes sir
does the implant have its own battery
yes it does oh you mean the eternal
implant yes no it does that's where the
really interesting things about it it's
got two computer chips inside it
something's got them on the way it works
is that the heavy
is sending data by radio through the
skin antenna inside the implant picks up
the radio signal but it also uses it to
induce an electrical currents elect
radio can be converted into electricity
so use that both as a source of data and
as a source of power so the implant here
is actually controlling this processor
and the internal processor yes sir
you did an incredible amount of
remapping to get away your ask could you
speak up the the implant and in the
beginning you did an incredible amount
of remapping that to get where you're at
now since the book has been published I
mean what is your situation I mean it in
remapping to get better nobody asked me
how many mapping sessions I have to go
through or I was like to go through
those sessions um where are you at right
now in getting to a more I guess okay
stable first let me just introduce the
concept of mapping now there are some
audiologists and in there with cochlear
implant users in the audience so this be
very familiar to some of you
what mapping is the process of tweaking
the values of the software in the device
there are many parameters that can be
changed by the audiologist the patient
can change some parameters like volume
and sensitivity for their many other
parameters that the audiologist can
tweak because every year is different in
particular every damaged ear is
different because damaged ears are
damaged in different ways so cochlear
implant very much has to be custom
fitted to the ear and that process of
custom fitting is called remapping so I
went through about five or six mapping
sessions in my first year and in those
sessions mean approximately closer and
closer toward a map which worked well
for me now that I'm about three and a
half years plus implant I haven't had a
mapping session in about two years
I pretty much stabilized on a map that
works well for me now whenever I get a
new software
have to go through a mapping process
again however the audiologist can
extrapolate from my old software and
insert those values into the new
software so that it's not completely
starting fresh all over again so with
most patients their Maps tend to
stabilize after year or so nonetheless
it is a complex process so let me read a
little bit about you know let me read a
little bit about it what was like an
activation to give you a sense of what
that was like so that's in Chapter four
okay so I'm going to start reading on
page 50 I'm going to read about two and
a half pages I can let me start on page
52 sorry
and there are two characters in the
scene there is Becky audiologist and
cash who is another audiologist then
cast turns to me and says the big moment
he warns me that I may not like it that
it may sound robotic where voices may
sound like minimaps i nod deep down I
don't believe I think it'll sound better
than that
and I see that the audio that what he's
a smart they because you've been through
this many times
Benny hits his laptop's Enter key static
it's like when nerfing the sidewalk and
Robocop first opens his eyes all he sees
as TVs know all I hear is static there's
a pervading roaring sound that I can't
even begin to locate everything sounds
awful muddy and incomprehensible I
stammer out something just to hear my
voice and it sounded like rusty train
wheels squeaking through mud I've got
the expression of a man who's just
swallowed what he thought was Pepsi only
to find that's actually pepto-bismol
cash and Becky do a few exercises to put
my New Year through its paces I close my
eyes to eliminate lip-reading at the
each beside the day's the week in turn I
can make me pick out the singsong
cadence but I can't be sure when one
person has stopped and another person
has started even worse I can't tell
their voices apart then we try assorted
words I get a few of them I scream
telephone what I'm wrong as often as
right give me as hatton as I say I'd
like that something I can contextualize
I'm feeling like a man skinning down a
hill
wrapping around for anything to slow the
fall care says this wasn't perverted
again I say these days phase four
versions I sign a spinach and spinach
and cheese omelet I say everyone wars in
the light except me I got it right but I
know that I'm doing it based on the
cadence of the things and the one
syllable I could actually feel that I've
heard the verse out in breakfast it's
like solving a crossword puzzle all I
needed was one or two letters and a bit
of context it's mid-morning after all
I'm not actually hearing you now give me
a sentence I can't predict as high again
I experienced a woodling sensation that
I just learned correspond to speech but
it's like squinting at a poster through
yards of fog the words color is black
and dog surface somewhere in my mind as
if someone were telepathically beaming
the words into my cortex again I say
trying for confirmation cache repeats
and sends a third time I frown this
can't be right for what I think I'm
hearing is what color is your black dog
over my eyes Cassius smiling and nodding
that's what I said it's hard to me to
argue with this the things to find my
expectations what I got it anyway
I must have heard it a scowl line it
doesn't feel like I heard you it felt
like guessing and it does it feels like
reading a page with half the letters
whited out one might be able to ski it
over and get the gist but it isn't going
to feel like reading it will get better
Becky says it will get better
Katherine's margaret and paula helpfully
give me excited thumbed up signs
better how
I'm thinking even if it gets twice as
good as this it's still going to be
terrible the session comes to a close as
I stand up I'm so stiff but I have to
crank my head back and forth a couple of
times to unlock my neck I pay the fee
from being switched on and walk out on
wobbly feet so that's what I heard
the first hour after arms after medium
so in a bit I'll be a little bit about
different kind of software which is
getting it son of the philosophical
themes of the book in fact let me jump
right into that section now and then
we'll break for a few more questions so
I'm going to be talking about two
different kinds of software called CIS
and sis now CIS and SAS have now been
phased out so these are outdated pieces
of software this was back in 2001 but
just key give you an inkling as is fired
all of the electrodes all of the time
CIS sorry did I just say CIS SAS wires
all the electrodes all the time CIS
fires just one of the electrodes and any
given instant but it's drugs among them
so rapidly get the illusion that all the
electrodes are being fired
it's like television where only one line
on the screen is actually being lit in
any given instant it just happened so
fast that you give you a losing of
continuous motion
so the two programs are profoundly
different ways of stimulating the
auditory nerve endings so here I want to
talk a little bit about how that sounded
to me so I'm going to start on page 72
about halfway down the page
so over the next few weeks I
experimenting I thumbed my dials
endlessly wind chimes on CIS wind chimes
on SRS mom's voice on CIS mom's voice on
SAS Mian serious me on SNS I soon
discovered that CIS and SAS had very
different ways indeed of handing me the
world see is the first program I had
looted activation gave me this revenge
for murders SAS gave me blood your heart
for orphans CIS made the world sound
quiet metallic and tinny SAS made it
sound big blocky and fuzzy see is minced
as I asked a loved see is that me sound
deadly with chopsticks SAS threw it at
me Indrani shovelfuls one new version of
the world would be unsettling enough if
the sky is suddenly always green you can
at least decide to accept that as
reality and do your best to get used to
it but if you have a choice between
world where the sky is green and pink in
the other your sense of reality goes
right out the window I had never heard
the world minding or galumphing shop
licked or shoveled to be sure the
implants liver dois decibels
I could hear clock ticking across a room
but I did not feel like a hearing person
a hearing person ha I was a receptor of
a flood of data which I was constantly
stitching into meaningful language a
half second or so after I actually heard
it and my performance outside the
testing booth was terrible with even
minor background noise or on the phone
and lost people's words like saw dust in
the wind all I knew was that I had two
different versions of reality and they
both sounded wrong so let's break for a
couple more questions yes sir just
curious about your perception of the
difference between sort of solving three
different phases where you had hearing
that wasn't wasn't perfect and then when
you went totally deaf and now are there
things that were positive when you were
totally deaf or the things that you
missed from that phase or was it all
just you're just glad that's sort of
behind you so if I understand you like
you asked me about you asked me if
there's anything that I miss about being
totally deaf and well let's just start
off with that question that's a very
interesting question
um you would think that going totally
deaf would be a nightmare and you would
be right because it cut me off from the
social world the biggest problems that I
couldn't use a telephone I could still
have conversations with people one on
one the lip reading skills were very
helpful and I stopped a little bit of
hearing left in the right ear so all of
a sudden my right ear became really
really important to me so I became much
better at lip-reading than I had ever
dreamed I could become as a matter of
fact I would say that three months in
which I was totally deaf was not the
most alive times of my life
smallest side of my life where I felt
the most engaged with people and with
the world because the experience of
going deaf was such shocking and such
sudden that my response was to marshal
all my energies and say this just
happened I'm going to go through it and
solve this poem and I knew about
cochlear implants as a matter of fact
the damn with deaf I flew back in Tahoe
back to San Francisco and you know my
mother what is an audiologist so I
already knew something about cochlear
implants so it was the sense of terror
and despair
I knew the technology was out there I
didn't know whether I would be
and for the technology but I knew that
was there and I knew that I was in for a
profound change now I never think to
myself as I flew back you know I might
be able to get a book out of this
experience I actually thought that I
swear so he was a very lifetime it in
lifted me out of that humdrum routine
and it gave me this very exciting
process and technology confronts I was
also very scary
one morning elves gave me the implant if
you can't be a person the implant with a
casing that can be removed so I could
actually open it up and look at the
circuitry inside and what overwhelming
thought was oh my god it really is a
computer because I could see the two
computer ships and was very clear that
they were hundreds of thousands of
transistors in the thing and this is
going to go inside he's going to
actually control a part of my here so it
was terrifying but it's also incredibly
exciting because I've been a
science-fiction geek all my life so
science fiction that's another big thing
the book so thank you for asking the
question because it lets me get into the
theme the book which really you know
something really love to talk about you
know there are many movies out there
Hollywood which depict cyborgs in one
way or another and a psych ward is a
fusion of the human and machine would be
more accurate a few a computer and human
being so I was going to come someone who
was both with par computer and part
human and I had seen Robocop I had seen
the Terminator I'd read Martin Caidin
novel cyborg which was the inspiration
for the Six Million Dollar Man and all
of those are about they try to convey
what the experience is like in one way
or another and so I came to this
experience with that science-fiction
framing my expectations so I was about
to find out how white were they and I
was actually very excited so in the book
I talk about that so in many ways
science fiction have gotten it
completely more
so for example the Borg and Star Trek so
how many here Star Trek fans okay well
okay one person but thank you very much
for being in the audience I know we have
another Star Trek fan over here so in in
Star Trek there are these creepy
characters called the board which all
these mechanical electronic parts of
their bodies and it turned them into
shambling robots so there's this
reflexive assumption that having
technology integrated within your body
makes you in you and I think that's
absurd but people just make that
assumption reflexively so I want to
confront that in the book okay so thank
you for letting me take that question
far feel from your original question
well what let's have another question
yes I've heard that some parents of deaf
children strongly oppose cochlear
implants why would that be okay the
question is I've heard that some parents
of deaf children and in fact some deaf
people strongly opposed cochlear
implants and the reason is there is a
subset of the deaf community
that's the signing deaf community the
primary language is American Sign
Language now American Sign Language is
not transcribed Inc it's not
fingerspelling we spell out English
words one letter at a time
American Sign Language is a completely
different language than English that
means that people have learned ASL from
childhood for them English is a second
language and it's often a poorly learned
one because they don't have access to
the sound of English so people grow up
being fluent ASL or effectively living
you know linguistic subculture they have
their own language their own culture
their own way of life and so some people
fear quite reasonably in my opinion that
have young deaf children get cochlear
implants the parents will not be
motivated to send them into the signing
deaf community they fear that it is a
harbinger of the ending of a way of life
the ending of a language the
the community that's what's at the
bottom of that resistance now that said
um in my [ __ ] I talk about my perception
of how attitudes have changed in some
members of the signing deaf community
there's a university for the signing
debt called Gallaudet in 1993 student
protests forced the cancellation of a of
a seminar of cochlear implants in 2001
however there's a survey and 59% of
Gallaudet faculty and students agreed
that the university should encourage
students with cochlear implants to
attend so there's been a sea change in
some people's attitudes over time
however the basic issue of the future of
ASL I think it's don't very much up in
the air and I did talk about that
extensively in chapter 8 of my book and
also one of the things that makes the
issue you must be charged for me let me
say first of all I don't speak ASL I was
always raised as an oral deaf person my
parents didn't know ASL so I never
learned as though I never spent time
with ASL speakers because my period made
the choice that I should learn to speak
in here English but ASL is such a rich
vital and vibrant community and it's a
world in which I might have felt fully
included and fully at home so just
before my talk today I was talking to
remember in the audience and has a son
who has profound hearing loss and who
wears hearing aids when you're in that
situation you're neither in the hearing
world nor in the signing deaf world it's
an awkward place in between I've always
been at that awkward place in between so
I feel a sense of of envy for the
signing deaf community to live in a
world where you can communicate
effortlessly I've never had that
experience so for me it's a very
emotionally charged and resonated
question as it is for many members of
the signing deaf community it's a great
question thank you can take one more
question they do another reading yes
if you had not been a candidate for the
cochlear implant or if in the future
something should happen to make it
impossible to continue to use it would
you put your energy into learning to
sign absolutely because it would be
first my only choice it's like an ASL is
a beautiful and fascinating language so
as a matter of fact if cochlear implants
have been available I probably wouldn't
written a book about that transition
from the hearing world
it's the signing deaf world and some
people have done that it would be
another transformative adventure so I
certainly would have done that is how is
an extraordinary language um you know
just give you a slight flavor of it
again I don't speak as an ASL speaker I
just speak of someone who is read about
ASL and who has talked to people about
ASL you know English has rats of
synonyms so for the word good there's
marvelous terrific magnificent amazing
cool ASL has a small number of signs for
good when you reflect them with your
body language so you can precisely
convey how good something is by the way
you hold your body by the way you make
your face light up so is that was an
incredibly good language for telling
jokes for telling stories for gossiping
for shooting the breeze it's
extraordinary language and an
extraordinary community so I absolutely
would have done that if cochlear
implants are not available and some
people do make that choice but I chose
to being a hearing person and that was a
choice I'm very grateful than medical
technology gave me the choice okay no
yes some people speak two languages they
speak French and they speak English or
Russian and agree with it is there some
reason not to do both if you have a
cochlear implant this is okay it's a
great question question is why not be
violent you why not simply speak both
ASL and English and that is certainly
possible however there is a difference
you can be bilingual and say Russian and
English or Spanish in French but it
helps that two functioning ears for that
so if you have a hearing loss and if you
learn eight if you learn ASL that's
great but it's very hard to learn a
spoken language so it's not quite the
same thing because people who are deaf
don't have the access to spoken language
that people with normal ears do now some
parents do wrestle with the question of
whether to teach their children both
English and ASL and some parents you try
to devote however it is difficult if the
parents don't speak as though in fact
96% of the deaf children born in this
country are born to parents who don't
speak air so only 4% are born to parents
whose native language is ASL so finally
give a loyalty it's possible practice in
theory and practice I think it's
challenging to achieve okay let me give
you another piece from the book and
we'll wrap up at around 8
so let me city what's marine now I think
I will read a piece about a piece of a
Radio Shack so let me flip to that page
so this was a couple of days after I was
activated to celebrate my new year I go
out to buy my first portable CD player I
want to play my familiar old CDs as a
way of mapping my new auditory world
onto my old one
now I help bolero sounds or any rate did
sound through hearing aids and cochlear
is missing most of their hair cells will
help me reconnect to reality whenever
exactly that is these days I start by
going to RadioShack to get a cable which
will enable me to connect the CD player
directly to the processor the processor
has an audio input jack for just this
purpose I'm greeted immediately by young
attentive and rather expressionless
employee what can I do for you I'd like
to get a patch cable to connect to a CD
player
I say you're connecting it to a speaker
he asks I have a thing how do I explain
this I decided to give him the short
first I let him ask questions to figure
it out in his own way I point to the
processor input jack and my waist I'm
going to plug it into this now before I
go on let me just say that there are two
different versions of the processor I'm
wearing the ear level version which
looks like a hearing aid there's another
verse it looks like a pager and it says
on the on the waist and that processor
has an audio input jack it's what you
plug just about anything so that's the
version of the processor that I'm
talking about I point to the process of
input jack in my waist I'm going to plug
it into this but he doesn't ask any
questions he leads me to the back and
rummage is authoritative lis among
cables hanging in plastic bags he can't
do my consisting of three jacks on each
end a study this doesn't look like it
should only have one plug on each end
you're going to plug it into a speaker
he says again
ah no I say I point to the processor at
my waist and then to the back of my head
this is a bionic year the past cable
will go in here then the sound will go
into my head
he simply nods and turns back to the
cables on the wall I'm a little be
funnelled maybe his customers walk into
the store all the time
asking how to plug things into
themselves he fix out a cable and hand
it to me can I try this out first I say
I want to make sure it works he muscles
up a CD player from the display case and
slide the discs into me I peek at the
label it's country-and-western
he keeps the player in his hands which
unnourished me because I don't know what
the heck is going to happen I entertain
a brief vision of a searing pain in my
head followed by both me and my credit
card
dropping limply to the floor kill it by
George Stream well if I can't control
the CD at least I can yank the path
cable out really really fast I ought to
recently take hold of the end on my side
just before he presses the play button
it's music the sound quality isn't all
that great but the feed comes through
clearly an hour later I'm home with a
patch cable and a new walkman as I sit
down on the couch to listen Elvis artis
is back involves belly up to greet me
and as you can tell the contacts Elvis
is my cat okay not Elvis the musician
you know I'm a totally deaf man was a
cat need for a musician it occurs to me
that there's no way he can hear the
music if I were running half times he'd
be able to hear whatever little bit of
sound leaked out but I'm plugged
directly into the player its output goes
directly it's the processor which
converts it to binary and pass it on to
the implant the implant decide which
electrodes to trigger in my cochlea
there are no physical vibrations
anywhere
all Elvis is ever going to hear is a
slight hum of the player itself I'm
hearing music that never actually exists
as sound this creepy evidence of the
profound transformation and how your
beings taking information from the world
around them or it could just be a cosy
domestic scene a cyborg and his cat
bolero zips by energetically
accelerating as it goes Elvis in music
attentive little cat sigh I can feel his
breath coming out his nostrils and lays
his head on my arm so anyway I gossip
for the picture of Elvis on my website
and by the way I have business cards
which will pass out which give my
website which is www.hyken.com so you
can go there and you can actually
download the first chapter and you can
also download clips there are
simulations of what the world sounds
like through a cochlear implant they're
actually fascinating so you know highly
recommend that people listen to them and
often it's actually kind of shocking for
people to listen to those simulations
because it makes you realize that as
amazing as a cochlear implant ends it's
not a substitute for a normal ear it
doesn't fix the ear what it does is it
creates a simulation of hearing it's not
perfect but a very proud of the fact
that I can and do use a cell phone that
is extraordinary that is a signal
achievement that in this day and age it
is possible to totally deaf people to
use cell phones so anyway we have just a
couple of minutes left so let's take a
couple more question then we'll wrap up
yes do you feel I did
as a deaf person yes I do
math because is that the thing comes off
on deaf so biologically I end up the
reason I here is because a computer is
doing a hell of a lot of data processing
for me so yes I still consider myself
very much a deaf person
I'm also present with a hearing loss so
I still have to struggle to hear things
sometimes the person will call me my
cell phone not to say I'm sorry I can't
just tell me who you are so that I can
contextualize what you're saying so I
certainly have to work harder to hear
that a person with normal hearing I my
right ear is still deaf so I still have
only one functional year by the way I
haven't seated getting an implant in my
right ear
my surgeon is urging me to do this and
maybe I will do it something but right
now there's no crisis you know it's a
very dramatic process to go through
maybe someday I will do it question is
there any other technology that besides
just better and better micro processors
or software that they're doing for
people with your sort of hearing loss so
you asking other other technologies than
cochlear implants that are used for
hearing loss
laughs well there are all sorts of
research going on about deafness and one
way or another there's a very exciting
stranded research which is focusing and
actually regrowing that damaged hair
cells inside the cochlea it may actually
be possible someday to cure deafness a
cochlear implant is a prosthesis it
simulates hearing but science isn't
doing research in two ways of regrinding
hair cell and that may indeed be
possible so that's very exciting there's
research going on of course in better
hearing aids hearing aids are improving
all the time
there's also Nicias like there are this
kind of hearing aid called the Baha
which is actually implantable hearing
aid and there are other kinds of hearing
aids which physically no the small bones
in the inner ear so there are a whole
range of technologies available for
people who are deaf and hard of hearing
so if you know someone who is a hearing
loss and if they haven't been to an
audiologist in the last five years it's
definitely time to go again because the
field is exploding all sorts of new
technologies and new therapies it's a
very exciting time yes we had a question
here
can you guess all you had a personal I
wondered how long
you mentioned that difficulty when you
first got the implant how long did it
take you to adjust to that and be able
to discriminate sound well the question
is how long did it take me to adjust to
what I first heard when I was activated
how long did tank work this vis vis
proverb is to sound like what did you
have for breakfast if the first say that
it's different for everybody it depends
very much on your hearing history adults
we've had normal hearing from most of
their lives tend to adapt very rapidly
to cochlear implants because they have a
fully functional wynnejoy cortex young
children tend to adapt very rapidly to
cochlear implants I'm actually somewhere
in the middle because I was a person who
never had normal hearing therefore I'm
an underdeveloped or Detroit cortex so
we took probably longer for me than it
would take for many other people so I
say um you know as you could tell from
that excerpt that I read I was getting
benefit the first thing the first day I
was getting environmental sounds I can
hear a clock ticking 20 feet away that
first thing I'm saying going to talk
about a month for the telephone to
become somewhat intelligible to me maybe
four or five months for me to become
comfortable and using the telephone and
actually the telephone comes up over and
over and over in this book because the
phone is the ultimate test for a
cochlear implant user if you can use the
telephone you can hear so for me it's
our the timeframe with weeks and months
and even now three and a half years
later you know I'm still discovering
that I can hear things that I hadn't
heard before so it's always an evolving
process so it is different for everyone
okay we had I think a question there yes
sir a technical question one is on you
comment in the book about using software
that other people have written has it or
anybody any people hacking their own
digital hearing aids or their implants
does anybody release the source you know
it's a great question questions anybody
hacking their own coder in flood now we
have two more dollars in the audience
may know more about this than I do so
feel free to speak up I would love to be
able to hack my own covenant blood I
definitely love to be able to get a hold
on to the laptop and Soundwave the
software used to program my employment
and start fussing around the parameters
I don't think one else would ever allow
we will do it because you know I think
in theory you could create parameters
that could harm your ear so you've got
me the hands of responsible professional
but nonetheless I would love to be able
to play with my own parameters I do know
that it's some cochlear implant centers
they do get some patients um they did
let them directly control the laptops
instead some of their own parameters and
I would love to do that so different
centers have different styles basically
um and need some day you know I will be
able to persuade the maker my implant
Advanced Bionics
so let me have some wave but you know I
would have to know a great deal about
you know the mechanics of the software
wait years work there's also into
technical terms you know what do y'all
just spend years going to school to
learn these things and there's a good
reason for it now it's not the kind of
thing where you just kind of figure out
in half an hour okay so I don't know if
anybody who does um do okay done like
the one else know of anybody who does
you see for digital hearing aid I don't
know either and in order to do that kind
of hacking you have to have the physical
connection to the device so comfortable
I need to physically be able to connect
to it you can't just plug it into your
PC and start pulling around with it well
maybe through an electrical engineer
okay I'm not an electrical engineer okay
what was your second question second
question is related to that is
how you use your cell phone as a drink
yeah Bluetooth in your that would
eliminate the pickle the question is how
do I use my cell phone
yeah um well bluetooth would be great um
I don't know of any company that's
actually researching that right now what
I use it is that the way people normally
hearing you I just stick it up against
my ear now I actually didn't explain my
devices microphone very well I say that
sound goes in the microphone here and it
can but this device the microphone is
actually here it's a very clever design
because it takes the advance of the
curve of the year so it takes bands like
thumb bounces off the shell the year
into the microphone so it adds two
decibels of sound to the signal it also
makes it much easier you need a cell
phone
because I can put it right there now
that took some getting used to for me
because with hearing aids a microphone
is technically on the front of the
device like around here so I had a
lifetime experience putting the phone
here and I still nothing by myself put
it here
another God tell you another funny story
and then we will wrap up Chris it's
exactly eight o'clock um when I first
got this t-mike I was just sitting there
typing stuff my laptop by accident I
kind of wrapped my arms around my head
like this
and I suddenly discovered that I stopped
hearing oh my god
took my hand off a guy the size thing
here yeah
whoa now I can hear here's a bizarre
experience doesn't experience that
everybody normal hearing takes for
granted but for me the center of my hair
and can never be it here it always been
here or here or even here sometimes so
it took me a while to get used to the
fact that my hair was actually here you
know it's experience that the other six
billion people in the planet take for
granted three it was totally new I felt
like a three-year-old
so and that's the kind of experience
that you have over and over again with a
cochlear implant just to wrap up you
know that is one of the biggest themes
of my book with life learned how to live
in a new kind of body in a body whose
rules are different and in a body whose
rules
can be changed over and over and over
again okay you've been a wonderful
audience